diese woche wird der truppenübungsplatz
seetaler halbe ungewandelt zur
teststrecke für unbemannte fahrzeuge
aller art
das amt für rüstung und wehrtechnik
bietet zusammen mit der technischen
universität graz kooperationspartnern
die möglichkeit ihre entwicklungen
abseits von asphaltierten im untergrund
einmal so richtig zu testen autonomes
fahren hat ja auch immer mit der
sicherheit und dem schutz zu tun nämlich
dass sich unter dem schutz unserer
soldaten die ja bei gefährlichen
missionen im einsatz sind jetzt muss ein
weiterer schritt gesetzt werden und an
diesen drei tagen konnten sehr viele
erkenntnisse gewonnen werden weil wir
uns hier im alpinen gelände offroad
sozusagen befinden unter ich habe jetzt
von einigen schon gehört da ein wirklich
wichtiger schritt neue erkenntnisse die
in diesen drei tagen gewonnen werden
konnten verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner verschafft sich am donnerstag
einen überblick über die ersten
forschungsergebnisse für autonom
fahrende fahrzeuge werden also abseits
von straßen markierung und co getestet
das ist ein faktor der firma vl
entwickelt unter anderem für unsere
projektanforderungen das ist software
gesteuert fahren kann also anhand von
befehlen und wir haben da gemeinsam mit
dem österreichischen bundesheer dem abc
hier ein projekt aufgesetzt wo es darum
geht autonom ihm gelände anhand den
anforderungen des österreichischen
bundesheers zu entwickeln und diese
anforderungen setzen voraus dass alle
fahrzeuge unter anderem ohne gps
unterstützung sich in jeder umgebung
zurechtfinden müssen
eine der größten herausforderungen für
die forscher die navigation erfolgt rein
kamera passiert das heißt mit
algorithmen basierend auf künstlicher
intelligenz die die kamera drathen
wir haben hier acht kameras die eine
rundumsicht garantieren das militär
verlangt natürlich jetzt dass man eine
sensorik verwendet die was nicht
imitiert und vielleicht auch kein gps
also dann sagen wir irgendwo wo man sagt
okay dann muss man jetzt mit kamera
passiert da unten zu setzen
deshalb ist dieses testfahrzeug mit
jeder menge kameras ausgestattet die für
den computer bei der berechnung der
umgebung unentbehrlich sind
bei attentaten punkte der verwendet um
zu schauen nämlich berges bewegen kann
und welche nicht bei uns
in dem versucht den partien vor gegeben
habe so zu fahren dass ein möglichst für
ob schon von denen heute
[Musik]
dieses ziel genannt die begleitfahrzeug
ist er dafür ausgelegt hindernisse im
gelände zu bewältigen und nicht zwingend
zu umfahren
denn seine aufgabe ist es das schwere
gepäck eines soldaten im einsatz zu
transportieren das schwere gepäck das
heutzutage tragen muss soldat muss mehr
als 75 kilogramm teilweise tragen für
ihn zu tragen autonom hinterher zu
transportieren und damit im einsatz
unterstützen der titel folgt also dem
soldaten dem ihr zugeordnet wird
erste tests bei der deutschen bundeswehr
kunden bereits erfolgreich durchgeführt
werden genau in deutschland haben wir
mit speziell für die schwere infanterie
getestet mit der deutschen bundeswehr in
lehnin übungsplatz die plattform sehr
gute kritiken bekommen aufgrund der
hohen mobilität nun hohen autonomie vor
allem einsatz schweres gelände waren
gelände wald um autonomes fahren für den
militärischen bereich umsetzen zu können
sind eine vielzahl an militärischen und
zivilen stellen eingebunden
die am beispiel robert huff deutlich
wird wonach ist ein forschungsprojekt
gefördert von der ffg wo wir im
zusammenarbeit mit mehreren partnern
das ist es zum beispiel dass awd vom e
mails aus der eu graz in zweifacher
ausfertigung also wie das institut für
software technologie und das institut
für geodäsie +2 industriepartner 1000
bereich mapping also für
kartendarstellungen das zweite ist ein
robotics data plus des dezernates dieses
der kompetenz netzwerk aus zwei anderen
autonomen navigation im alpinen bereich
wahr werden diese vielen
kooperationspartner machen es möglich
dass in zukunft bei katastrophen
hilfseinsätzen des bundesheeres noch
schneller geholfen werden kann ohne
dabei einsatzkräfte selbst in gefahr
bringen zu müssen also grundsätzlich
geht es darum dass wir die größe
kleinere
einige große transportaufgaben
übernehmen das heißt im alpinen bereich
sich zb bei einer lawinensituation dass
man durch den gefahrenbereich zum
beispiel güter oder oder ausrüstung
transportiert und natürlich niemanden
auf dem fahrzeug darauf hat der
gefährdet ist
das zweite wäre dann auch unterstützung
von der bergrettung aufbringen von
material oder auch vielleicht einer
verletzten abzutransportieren relativ
frische anfrage in die skates ist zum
beispiel waldbrandbekämpfung diese
serien zu müssen intensiv und es ist
sehr fordernd für die kollegen boris
jede unterstützung
begrüßenswert wo man dann auch material
oder vielleicht auch wasser
transportieren kann um die autonom
fahren die unterstützung in naher
zukunft auch in den realen einsatz
bringen zu können sind kooperationen für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
unumgänglich ist es unabdingbar
notwendig auch für unser amt für
rüstungs und wehrtechnik dass diese
schritte gemeinsam gesetzt werden mit
der wissenschafter mit der technischen
universität aber auch mit der wirtschaft
alleine wäre so ein schritt in die
zukunft im bereich der militärpolitik
sicher nicht möglich
[Musik]